bonjour jean marc sylvestre alors on va
au devant d'une crise de l'assurance qui
va s'ajouter à la crise économique qui
va encore noircir la situation comment
expliquer tout cela
écoutez vous l'avez dit les assureurs
aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas indemniser
les victimes du coc u19 ils ne le
peuvent pas parce que c'était pas
forcément prévus dans les contrats
mais ils ne le peuvent pas surtout parce
que ça leur coûterait extrêmement cher
et qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens de le
faire d'autant que les réassureurs le
refus s'il faut savoir que les assureurs
que l'on que l'on connaît qui assure les
automobiles les habitations des
entreprises axa massive groupama gan à
d'autres on va pas citer toutes les
marques
et bien c'est assurant là sont eux mêmes
garanties contre les très gros risques
par des sociétés internationales
auxquelles elles cotisent certaines sont
britanniques comme munich ré d'autres
sont françaises à une entreprise
française très puissante la score mais
c'est pas la seule quand il ya une
catastrophe aérienne
où est le naufrage d'un cargo par
exemple qui provoquent une énorme
pollution d'une marée noire
et bien c'est réassureur interviennent
en appui en inde et bien aujourd'hui ses
réassureurs la vienne dire qu'ils ne
pourront pas indemniser les dégâts
causés par le cos vite si pas simplement
français c'est internationale et s'est
notamment britanniques hors locaux vides
c'est évidemment une catastrophe qui a
fait des dégâts humains des morts et qui
continue d'en faire mais qui aussi mis à
plat tous les systèmes économiques
donc vous avez des entreprises qui ont
perdu leur exploitation des commerçants
qui n'ont pas travaillé les hôteliers
par exemple et qui voudraient bien
récupérer une sorte de compensation
mais alors d'où vient le problème
vraiment d'abord vous avez des assureurs
qui ont déjà payé un lourd tribut à la
crise vous avez des assureurs qui sont
déjà intervenus pour compenser par
exemple des annulations d'événements ou
des remboursements de billets d'avion de
voyage mais qui ne peuvent plus
intervenir je vous le disais il ya un
acheteur parce que les contrats qu'ils
ont signés ne permettent pas de couvrir
les risques aussi grave
d'autant que ça n'est pas le virus qui a
provoqué les dégâts
les dégâts sur le résultat des décisions
gouvernementales de confiner le virent
ce n'a pas stoppé les avions les bateaux
les usines cela c'est l'administration
qui a pris cette décision là pour
protéger la vie humaine du coup les
assureurs se retourne vers les états
pour qu'ils paient exactement comme
quand il ya une catastrophe naturelle
une inondation par exemple l'état vient
en garantie des assureurs
mais aujourd'hui les états ne viendront
pas soutenir les assureurs pourquoi
parce que les états ne ont déjà fait un
certain nombre d'efforts il ya eu déjà
des plans de soutien de relance
la france par exemple a mobilisé 400
milliards en mars
elle vient de sortir un plan de relance
de 100 milliards et plus ça va
principalement en direction des
entreprises d'état faire à peu près ce
que font les grandes démocraties
occidentales
donc on ne peut difficilement aller il
ya un conflit entre les assureurs et les
états mais est ce que les assureurs ne
peuvent pas réviser leurs positions
alors squattent les assureurs vont
reprendre aujourd'hui sont en train de
reprendre tous les contrats importants
plus précisément pour écarter très
précisément la pandémie des risques
assurables il considère que si c'est une
catastrophe naturelle
ce sont les états de le faire ils
veulent surtout tu nous l'as couvrir
juridiquement et éviter les procès mais
sur le fond sur le fond on n'échappera
pas notamment l'année prochaine par
exemple à des partenariats entre les les
assureurs privés et le public pourquoi
parce que l'état lui-même risque d'être
gênés si la situation s'aggrave si la
croissance économique ne revient pas par
exemple en 2021
on aura de sérieux problèmes de
financement notamment budgétaires d'où
l'insistance avec laquelle il annonce
aujourd'hui que il refusera tout nouveau
confinement c'était vraiment le discours
de jean castex la semaine prochaine la
semaine dernière mais pour cela il faut
évidemment se protéger d'où le
durcissement des conditions sanitaires
les chaises les masques qui sont les
meilleures assurances contre le coc vide
19 actuellement
c'est évidemment pour l'état comme pour
les assureurs les moins chers merci jean
marc sylvestre pour toutes ces
précisions